hello um
thanks for attending uh my talk my name
is brent tomorrow i'm a professor of
neurobiology and statistics at the
university of chicago i'm also the
director for the grossman center for
quantitative biology and human behavior
this is a new center devoted to
theoretical neuroscience uh uh here at
the university of chicago we're excited
to to share our growth with you over the
next coming years but today i want to
talk about research that was funded by
the brain initiative uh conducted in my
lab in collaboration with several other
labs which i'll mention as we go through
and the title of my talk is dimensions
of variability in circuit models of
cortex here um
so uh
this is a recording one of the earliest
recordings known from cortex it's by
liam jasper uh in published in 1953
and uh it's a single unit recording
in cat visual cortex and the thing that
i think strikes many of us is the
seemingly random and erratic uh
uh state of cortical neurons here they
produce uh spikes at random times and
with random intervals between each other
there's a fair bit of variability that's
inherent in cortical response and this
has been something that's fascinated and
puzzled uh scientists ever since uh this
recording really
there's two ways to think about how
variability might come about
in a neuronal response the first one
would be that a neuron inherits
variability or a network of neurons will
inherit variability from a source that's
outside of the network here so here
we're thinking of the system as a true
stochastic system
the other framework
would be that variability is produced
internally within a network due to
complex interactions much more much akin
to a chaotic or turbulent dynamical
system here
my research group tries to navigate
between
these two distinct mechanisms for
variability and often trying to merge
them together to get a true appreciation
of variability in the nervous system and
this is what today's talk's going to be
about here
the data set that's going to motivate
this work is a collaboration with matt
smith at cmu and the data was collected
by sanji
they were doing a delayed match to
sample tasks in uh non-human primates
here where the animal had to fixate a
target one of 40 targets appeared
and then after some delay the animal had
to second to that target the interesting
thing about this data set is they were
simultaneously recording both from
visual area v4 as well as pfc during
during the task here
when we look at what's happening in v4
we see that uh uh for where the array
was positioned the majority of the
neurons uh were responsive to visual
input on the lower left uh uh hemi field
here and this is this is standard for
for v4 it's certainly going to encode
only for only one side of the visual
space here
when we compare this to what's happening
in pfc
uh even though we're only recording from
one side of pfc both uh sides of the
visual uh visual scene are recorded
or
neurons are responsive to both sides of
the visual seat we know this because uh
pfc receives information from both
left and right visual streams here so
pfc is really integrating the full
visual scene here
uh however what i want to talk to you
today is not the mean response or the
tuning curves of these cells i want to
talk about the variability inherent in
the system here and the way i'm going to
do this is becoming somewhat standard in
the field uh here on the left we have a
covariance matrix the spike chemical
variance matrix we might have 50 or 60
neurons simultaneously record it we have
many many trials and we look at the the
co variability across the population we
want to decompose this spike covariance
matrix into a shared component that
describes the joint variability of
neurons in the system uh and then an
independent component and we're really
interested in what's the effective
dimension of character variants how many
latent variables or eigenvectors do we
need to have to describe this up to some
level of tolerance here
when and a lot of this analysis or all
the analysis and modeling you'll see
here was done by a previous phd student
from my lab danielle rager here so
here's some analysis of
spike train variability in area v4 here
uh what danielle did here is she used
five eigenvectors to construct the
shared covariance matrix but even though
she used five really the first eigen
mode describes a ton of the variability
uh and when that's that's seen when we
look at the the eigenvalue of the first
one it's much much larger than the other
ones the weight of this eigenvector
loading onto the neurons uh uh is all
the same polarity so this is really
describing a framework where neurons in
v4 are waxing and waning their activity
in a trout to trial way in a coherent
manner
when we plot the amount of variability
explained as a function of the number of
latent dimensions we need uh we again
see here that even just with one latent
variable we get almost 95 percent of the
variability across our data set so this
is really saying v4 is really a
one-dimensional
source of variability here
when we do the exact same analysis from
prefrontal cortex we see that we need in
this particular data set on average
around four latent variables so it's
higher dimensional
the variability is more complex and more
structured in pfc than it is in v4 here
so uh this
poses a theoretical question for us and
this is where our modeling efforts are
going to start here uh a simple
hypothesis for why is it that pfc seems
to have higher higher dimensional
variability than uh area v4 is that well
pfc doesn't just receive inputs from v4
we know it receives input from both uh
v4s the one on the left and the one on
the right but it receives input from
other areas of the nervous system so
then here uh if each of these are
providing low dimensional sources of
variability then psc will integrate
these and then be higher dimensional
just through inheritance here and that's
sort of on the stochastic system
inheritance side of our continuum here
uh that's we can't discount this but
today what i want to do is explore the
other
possible uh mechanism here namely that
uh there is still just two sources of
variability a one-dimensional source
from the left v4 to one dimensional
source from the right before so that
would be sort of two dimensional inputs
coming into pfc but it's the internal
interactions within pfc that are able to
amplify and expand the dimensionality of
the inputs that it's receiving from v4
so i want to i want to propose uh and
explore this hypothesis in the remainder
of the talk here
so let's build a model of psc here so
i'm going to take a start with a
relatively simple model i'm going to
have a bunch of excitatory cells um
and they're going to be each model with
a simple leak integrate and fire style
spiking model here so neurons integrate
their inputs until there's a threshold
they produce a spike and then they reset
this is a common model used in many many
sections
uh and the connection strength between
neurons i'm going to have just random
structure within our network random
wiring with our network the connection
strengths are going to be fairly weak
here k is the number of presynaptic
inputs that a neuron will receive and
the strength of an of the connection is
proportional to 1 over k so the more
input the neuron receives the weaker and
weaker each individual input is in
proportional sense it's a sort of
standard weak coupling theory here
uh and i'm going to drive this input
this network with two one-dimensional
inputs one modeling the fluctuations
from the left v4 and one modeling the
fluctuations from the right b4 and these
fluctuations are going to be
one-dimensional so they're plus all
processes with a one-dimensional of a
fluctuating input that describes their
firing rates
so they're formally doubly stochastic
and now when we look at the spike train
responses in the raster plots on on the
left we see that uh the neurons that uh
a neuron a neuron psc is either gonna be
deemed a left uh uh left sensitive
neuron or a right sensitive neuron
meaning which v4 is it getting its
projections from and uh the collection
of pfc neurons that are getting inputs
from the left v4 they tend to track that
one-dimensional input from the left
similarly for the right
and given this very simple uh weakly
coupled system we can write down a
theory for this this network here uh y i
is gonna be the spike count response of
neuron i in our pfc network here and i'm
gonna take a linear theory here so
what's in the bracket is gonna be all of
the inputs that that ice neuron is going
to get the first term in the bracket is
all of the inputs that are coming feed
forward from from the v4 that it's uh
being driven by the second uh term
inside the bracket is all the recurrent
interactions within the network here and
you can see there's a yk there so there
this is a recurrently coupled network
here what gi is is basically going to be
the gain
function for that neuron so here i'm
going to take what's called the linear
response theory each neuron is formally
non-linear in terms of a transfer
function but there's going to be an
operating point that the network is
sitting at and i'm going to linearize
around that operating point
of that linearization is this gain gi
it's going to be different for each and
every neuron because of heterogeneity
but we can calculate what this gain is
for all of the neurons in our in our
network
uh if i have this real simple linear
framework we can write down
mathematically what the covariance of
the pfc network would be here and it's
this sort of uh
algebra soup here on that second line of
that that equation here i'll parse this
out for you
the first term here is the
co-variability that would be due to the
feed forward connection so that inner
matrix v that's the co-variability of
the v4 population uh of course it's
going through the feed forward
connection matrix jff and then that gets
passed through the gain of the neurons
to produce output correlations if there
was no recurrence in pfc that would be
the only thing we would have just
straight feet forward
the other two terms here are uh the
correlations that will be due to the
recurrent activity or this feed forward
input being passed through the
recurrence in the network here and they
uh they morph and change correlations
due to the wiring structure in the
network here but it's still relatively
straightforward to compute what the
total covariance would be here
uh when we when we uh test our theory
versus our simulations we get a really
good match here so these clouds of data
here at the the gray cloud is the
covariability of uh left and left
neurons the black cloud which is hidden
by the gray cloud is the covariability
of the right and right neurons and in
the in the corner near the origin uh is
the covariability of a right neuron with
a left neuron here that's an orange
there so our theory does a pretty good
job at capturing the numerics in our
simulation here
but if we take this theory uh and then
push it through sort of a well-known
theorem in linear algebra the
dimensionality or the rank of the
covariance matrix c y uh since it's the
product of a bunch of matrices it's
going to be the the rank of the minimum
component in these uh
sub sub matrices here and since the v4
input coming in was two dimensional the
left b4 was one dimensional the right v4
was one dimensional you take the sum and
that's two dimensional we have here that
the rank of the covariability in our
simple pfc model uh cannot be larger
than two it must be greater it must be
less than or equal to two that's a
well-established theorem and linear
algebra here and lo and behold when we
do factor analysis on this and ask how
many latent variables do we need to
explain a hundred percent of the
variability lo and behold if we have uh
uh one latent variable we get roughly 50
percent of the variability if we have
two latent variables we get 100 of the
variability in our model so uh this is
not a good representation for what's
going on here i'll remind you that uh
the data showed that the variability
wasn't well explained by two dimensions
but really on average four dimensions
here so this simple weakly coupled uh
model of pfc isn't going to cut it and
if we wanted to have higher if you
wanted to have a higher dimensional
activity in php it would need to come
from more outside sources our hypothesis
one that i'm not tracking here i want to
explain it with internal dynamics in pfc
so what are we going to do here well
let's make the coupling between cells
larger so let's take this one over k
coupling and turn it into what's uh one
over square root k coupling this is a
standard scaling that's familiar to
people that work in balanced network
theory and what balanced network theory
means is that the excitatory coupling is
fairly large one over square root k is
much much larger than one over k
uh and because recurrent excitation is
now quite impressive and quite large it
needs to be counteracted and balanced by
uh recurrent inhibition in the system
here
so we need to have excitatory inhibitory
cells to make sure that the system is
stable despite this large uh recurrent
coupling here so now we include
inhibitory cells we give them a right in
the left side projection from v4 as well
and when we do simulations for this
network we get really different dynamics
uh if we just do it as is here we get
bi-stable dynamics so that the the left
neurons uh which are on the top here
when they're firing vigorously they're
actively suppressing neurons that prefer
the right uh v4 and then vice versa you
get this bi-stable switching dynamics
that occur in this network a really
non-linear property this would not be
captured by a simple linear system uh
there's really two
two solutions here battling it out
um
this doesn't uh this when we look at
correlation structure we get that
neurons within the same uh preferring
the same
v4 input they tend to be positively
correlated neurons that prefer opposite
v4 inputs are negatively correlated and
this has been well described in papers
previously from my research group
this uh unfortunately doesn't exactly
look like the data while neurons that
prefer the same visual hemifield uh are
positively correlated that's in the the
blue and the and the cyan uh that's not
the case for neurons that uh one neuron
that prefers uh the left and when
they're not prefers right they're weakly
anti-correlated but not strongly
anti-correlate
we can break this uh this strong
anti-correlation by now taking our
network and coupling neurons in an
attractor framework here where neurons
that like the same and like the same
visual input tend to wire with one
another uh with stronger connections
here so this is this clustering
coefficient so on the left clustering
coefficient of one would mean that
there's no structure whatsoever in pfc
clustering coefficient of 2.4 means that
neurons that like the same uh hemifield
input
uh
tend to coupled with one another with a
strength of 2.4 that of the of the of
the opposite coupling here so
when we put this clustering into our
system we can get rid of this sort of
pathologic bistability that doesn't
really describe our network that well
here uh and that's what we see here if
the system becomes uh less and less uh
by stable as we put in higher and higher
clustering and again this is work that
has been explained in previous papers in
my lab
when we look at the dimensionality this
is new though no one's seen this when we
look at the dimensionality of our
network when our clustering is quite uh
when there's no clustering in our
network the dimensionality in the model
is uh still quite low that's the c
equals one solution as we put clustering
the model the the overall dimensionality
that we would pick up from factor
analysis grows uh and starts to match
what we saw in the data here reported so
this is somewhat satisfying and putting
uh attractor like networks in pfc is
relatively standard now we do think of
pfc as as a network that is tuned for
specific inputs
so let's go a little farther with this
so now that we can uh we have a model
that replicates the data in pfc
reasonably well let's sort of open the
hood of the car here and understand a
little bit more what we can do is we can
take the dynamics of our model and uh
segregate periods of time when the model
is such that the left uh
network is dominant over the right
that's
zones on the raster plot or periods of
time where the right is dominant over
the left that is in the orange periods
of time so we can segregate our network
into being into one of two states and we
these intermediate transition zones
we're going to throw them out of our
data set right now and not analyze them
here
so
when we restrict our network to being in
one of the two states in this particular
case the left state so that means
neurons that prefer the left input are
highly active and we do our our linear
theory where we estimate the gains and
we take our linear response functions we
do a pretty decent job at explaining the
covariability uh in the network um the
y-axis is the theory we would get from
fitting the the gains and using that
matrix formula there versus what we
measure from the simulations on the on
the the x-axis here and there's a pretty
decent job at explaining everything
despite the fact that the coupling is
fairly strong here remember this is the
strongly coupled network interactions
are quite impressive here but we
restrict our system to being in one of
in the state uh l here we get a pretty
decent job
if we restrict our system to being in
the state where the right the the right
uh pfc neurons are dominant over the
left we also get a pretty decent uh uh
match between theory and sense
um however if we look at the gain
function
we see that if we linearize our system
where the neurons are in the left state
versus the right state the gain does
change here so those gi's uh are
different depending on which state we
are in that's again a hallmark of a
nonlinear system so the the gain or the
slope of the transfer function of a
neuron changes depending upon which
state it's in effect sampling the
non-linearity of that neurons transfer
function and that's true for for all of
our neurons here
so
here this is sort of the last couple
slides here if we do our uh
dimensionality analysis and we ask
what's the uh cumulative variance uh
explained shared variance explained how
many dimensions do we need to explain 95
98 99 of the variance if we restrict our
system to being in one of the two states
either state r or state l it looks like
we just need two dimensions and that
makes sense from our linear theory
before there's two v4 inputs they're
both one-dimensional pfc is receiving
both of them if it's acting like a
linear system then it'll just inherit
the dimensionality of those v4 inputs
and you get the answer too
however if we look at the system
for the full dynamics where we're
allowing the transitions to happen
now in order to explain a high
percentage of the variability we need a
higher demand we need we need three or
three or more dimensions here and this
is because these two dimensional
manifolds given by the linearizations
are different depending on when you're
in whether you're in state r or state l
and the network is transitioning between
these and if you build a linear theory
that stitches these two things together
you can do a better job at this and this
is effectively saying well when you look
at the full system there's two
dimensional variability uh when the
system's in state are there's another
manifold which is two-dimensional when
the system is in state l and sort of the
the union of these two manifolds it's
effectively four dimensions here this is
sort of not not a proof in any sense but
sort of a uh a good way to think about
why variability the dimension of
variability is expanding when we go from
v4 to pfc it's the non-linearities in
pfc
that uh sort of sample uh different
regions of activity space here and uh
and amplify them
for inputs here
so some of the takeaways here from this
is that visual area v4 has very low
dimensionality while pfc shows a higher
dimensionality this expansion be from v4
to pfc in terms of dimensionality can be
captured if the pfc networks are
strongly coupled and they have a tractor
structure with their connectivity and we
can get a good understanding this of
this dimensionality expansion by
stitching together linearizations of the
network about distinct states here so
this is the beginning of a path that i'm
taking with my lab and my collaborators
to understand how
the dimensions of activity are are
transmitted across across cortical
networks as we start recording from more
and more regions of the brain
simultaneously these kinds of theories
will be more and more important to see
here uh my last slide is to give
acknowledgements here so really the the
the work uh majority of the analysis and
modeling work was all done by danielle
rager um who was a graduate student in
my lab now she works for ibm and her
neural norfolk chip division
uh and this is a collaboration with matt
smith as well as byron yu
and it really comes out from a brain
initiative award from the theories
models and methods for analysis of
complex data from the brain uh this has
been a great mechanism for me to receive
my lab and my collaborators to receive
funding so i thank you for that